boa tarde durante muitos anos desde que
a humanidade se organizou em grupos e
comunidades as mulheres estariam seus
filhos ao lado de outras mulheres em
suas casas com suas famílias na enorme
maioria das vezes
tudo corria bem é mais em muitos casos
aconteceu mortes de mulheres ou de seus
bebês por muitos milênios isso foi
aceito como parte natural da vida e da
seleção natural
isso durou até parte do século 19 quando
novas descobertas e tecnologias foram
incorporados ao conhecimento com um anti
sepsia os antibióticos anestesia a
cirurgia e os médicos começaram a atuar
com instrumentos instrumental específico
para parte complicados é a medida que o
conhecimento científico foi se
expandindo de forma muito rápida e o
sistema patriarcal foi dominando a
sociedade
as parteiras foram gradativamente sendo
excluídas do cenário do parto o que fez
também com que as mulheres fossem
perdendo o conhecimento sobre seus
corpos seus ciclos suas funções
fisiológicas
o fato é que nesse processo muitos
avanços foram conseguidos sendo que o
principal deles foi a redução acentuada
das mortes de mães e crianças
porém como em quase todos os aspectos da
nossa civilização nós exageramos nós
erramos a mão
então hoje no mundo inteiro as taxas de
cesáreas e intervenções nos partos
crescem ano a ano e isso não é
acompanhado de uma redução significativa
da mortalidade e de complicações durante
os partos
o brasil tem o desprazer de ostentar
hoje o vergonhoso título de campeão em
número de cesáreas e com uma taxa de
mortalidade materna ainda muito distante
dos objetivos do milênio acordadas com a
onu
nas últimas décadas vem crescendo um
movimento das mulheres e de uma corrente
de profissionais por uma mudança nesse
cenário chamado de movimento pela
humanização do parto e nascimento
então ele procura ali a arte das
carteiras com a ciência obstétrica
o que está se buscando na verdade é a
retomada do protagonismo da mulher
isso quer dizer o que é o respeito à
autonomia em relação a como onde e com
quem é essa mulher deseja ter seu parto
é inclui uma visão do parto como um
evento bio psico social família e
integrativo a inclusão dos aspectos
emocionais psicológicos e até
espirituais no processo já está em paris
inclui a prestar assistência por um
equipe transdisciplinar ou seja admite
incentivar a presença de outros
profissionais da assistência ao parto
como as enfermeiras obstétricas as
obstetrizes que são parceiras com
formação universitária e douglas todos
trabalhando de forma horizontal e
agregando seus saberes é prevê que as
intervenções do parto quando necessárias
sejam realizadas de forma racional e
criteriosa e com base em evidências
científicas ou seja não se exclui a
tecnologia mas sim seu abuso
essa mudança de paradigma já está
instalada na sociedade já está
acontecendo é uma crise instalada na
sociedade por causa desta mudança em
curso hoje as mulheres que querem ter um
parto respeitoso a gente brinca que elas
têm que praticamente matar um leão por
dia
elas querem na verdade que seus filhos
sejam recebidos neste mundo de forma
digna e que esse processo de formação do
vínculo e maternagem sejam também
respeitados
elas acreditam que são capazes de já
estar de pare e de maternar sem a tutela
ea imposição do poder médico querem que
o sistema médico na verdade seja seu
aliado e não seu algoz
essas mulheres elas estudam elas
informam elas decidem e elas fazem
opções da forma mais consciente possível
mas o que acontece muitas mulheres são
envolvidas e tomadas pela cultura do
medo do parto e medo da dor
e não tem acesso à informação de
qualidade
por outro lado os médicos e os
profissionais de saúde os familiares à
sua rede de contatos ea própria
sociedade
todo mundo deixou de acreditar no parto
com um evento fisiológico como um evento
normal seguro e que foi desenhado pela
natureza para funcionar
na maioria das vezes eles são levados
todo mundo é levado pelo senso comum
quem põe que o parto seja
necessariamente um evento médico e que
seja cercado de tecnologia
por outro lado a formação do médico é
voltada para a patologia para a doença e
há uma deficiência é na formação dos
médicos é na assistência no ensino da
assistência ao parto normal
eles são treinados na verdade para
intervir sempre pra salvar a mãe eo bebê
ea nossa sociedade de consumo
imediatista ela não tem mais paciência
na estrutura emocional para lidar com o
tempo necessário e com imprevisibilidade
do parto e muitas mulheres a hoje ainda
sofrem muitas violências no momento do
parto
tanto por parte de profissionais de
saúde como também por protocolo
institucionais rígidos além de péssimas
condições de atendimento
o que aconteceu é com toda essa crise os
órgãos e gestores de saúde pública
preocupados com esse cenário e pé e
pressionados também pelos movimentos
sociais é estão tentando criar
mecanismos para conter o avanço nas
taxas de cesáreas intervenções no parto
estão tentando incentivar a humanização
do parto e nascimento e melhorar os
indicadores de qualidade
tudo isso através da criação de diversas
políticas públicas como a rede cegonha a
criação de centros de parto normal
diretrizes resoluções é essa estratégia
no entanto esbarram numa série de
dificuldades
hoje existe uma crise política de
desconfiança e descrença nos gestores
nos governos
existe uma carência de leitos na rede
pública por falta de investimento por má
distribuição ea carência de leite também
na rede privada a rede privada é regida
pelas leis de mercado ea obstetrícia
principalmente obstetrícia fisiológica
não dá lucro aos hospitais há uma evasão
dos profissionais médicos da obstetrícia
e da neonatologia é uma ação que são
profissões muito
é difícil e muito é que exigem muito do
profissional
existe também uma disputa de poder entre
os médicos e as outras categorias
essa crise toda do sistema faz com que
as pessoas deixem de enxergar novos
caminhos e se percam em reuniões
intermináveis se queixando todo mundo se
fechando e reclamando do governo dos
gestores dos médicos dos enfermeiros das
mulheres todo mundo reclamando de todo
mundo e cada um se colocando nesse papel
de vítima inocente
eu sou médico obstetra
sou formado há 32 anos e minha prática
sempre foi voltada para o incentivo ao
parto normal a redução das intervenções
e respeito à fisiologia da gestação e do
parto eu trabalho em consultório privado
e atua também no setor público no centro
de parto normal da mansão do caminho
além de 30 anos trabalhando com o
obstetra na do ministério da saúde
meu último local de trabalho na
maternidade primeiro de oliveira que é a
maternidade escola da ufa
eu nos últimos anos eu andava descrente
também nem entrei nesse nesse modelo de
reclamar de tudo mas nos últimos cinco
anos minha prática profissional tanto no
serviço privado quanto no setor público
passou por uma série de avanços uma
série de mudanças que eu considero como
avanço por importantes
o principal a principal mudança que eu
fiz foi a incorporação do trabalho em
equipe com a valorização da enfermeira
obstetra com o seu saber próprio
experimentando e aperfeiçoando o
relacionamento horizontal entre os
profissionais
incentivamos também a presença de
douglas
profissionais que cuidam de oferecer
suporte contínuo físico e emocional
gestante
nós procuramos fazer uma integração
desses saberes e todos têm o objetivo de
prover a segurança eo bem estar da
mulher e do bebê
reforçando a confiança dela em si mesma
e no parto e interferindo o mínimo
possível no processo é todas essas
condutas e decisões são discutidas e as
responsabilidades são compartilhadas com
a mulher
nós incentivamos a procura de grupos de
apoio a gestantes e as mães tanto
presenciais quanto virtuais o que faz
com que elas trocam informações e
dialoguem com pessoas e profissionais
que falam a mesma língua aumentando sua
confiança
além disso nós profissionais contamos
também com a rede de apoio
nós temos colegas que atuam de forma
parecida na mesma cidade que nos dão
suporte em caso de intercorrências de
complicações e nos dão cobertura também
quando nós precisamos afastar de outras
atividades
nós também contamos com um grupo de
apoio e de discussão de casos através da
internet com profissionais que atuam
dentro de si mesmo paradigma são todos
os estudiosos pesquisadores professores
todos vinculados a medicina baseada em
evidência
essa rede nos dar suporte diante da
oposição e das críticas do sistema
médico dos colegas das instituições em
diante também do nosso próprio medo no e
ambivalência essas mudanças simples que
eu consegui fazer que é a ampliação do
olhar para outros horizontes
a ampliação do conhecimento estudo
constante da ciência obstétrica e de
outras áreas
essa formação de parceria e essas e esta
rede de apoio fizeram toda a diferença
na minha vida fizeram com que hoje eu
encontrasse um grande alegria e prazer
com o meu trabalho não só porque meus
indicadores de qualidade melhoraram mas
porque na verdade me fazem acreditar que
todo estudo
o que os dias e noites sem dormir vale a
pena pelo sentimento de estar prestando
um serviço em benefício de algo muito
maior
é eu hoje eu acredito que nós podemos
ser autor de nossa própria história que
nós podemos mudar os rumos de nossa vida
através de nossas escolhas e de nosso
alinhamento com essa intenção positiva
eu convido todos a refletir sobre o
papel que cada um de nós pode exercer a
fim de contribuir com essa mudança
porque nós realmente acreditamos que
nascer de uma forma respeitosa e não
violenta é o primeiro passo para a
grande mudança da humanidade e do
planeta
obrigada